To Kenya now, where a series of grim discoveries
in a river have local residents scared and
authorities looking for answers.
For months, dead bodies have been dumped into
the River Yala.
It's unclear who the people are, how they
died, or who is deposing of them.
DW's Felix Maringa has more on the mystery.
The river Yala pours into Africa’s largest
lake, Lake Victoria.
For months now, local residents have been
making a gruesome find – dead bodies in
various states of decomposition, that have
been dumped in the river.
I have no idea where these bodies are coming
from.
They are bound - some have their head tied
with nylon, other bodies are in a sack, others
have their hands tied.
People say some of the bodies they have found
show signs of mutilation or torture.
But the local doctor says he has found nothing
suspicious.
the type of injury that is manifested is basically
drowning.
We are not able to ascertain whether there
is any other type of injury on these bodies,
unless and until a postmortem is conducted.
Police and activist groups are giving differing
accounts of the number of dead.
Rights group Amnesty International has voiced
its concern and accuses authorities of down-playing
the matter.
We are here because we know that a minimum
of thirty bodies, a minimum of thirty bodies
have been found in the last 6 months.
So do not let anybody teach us or cheat us
that there were thirty bodies over the last
two years, that is not the truth, it is not
the truth.
Even more bodies have been retrieved from
the river this week.
People hoping to find missing relatives among
the dead have travelled from as far away as
Mombasa on the coast.
No one knows where these bodies are coming
from because this river is quite lengthy it’s
about 200 kilometers long, so the bodies could
be coming from even the neighboring counties.
Local police have been unable to provide answers,
leaving residents in the area terrified.
I’m afraid because I often watch football
at the local bars at night.
But now that we’re finding these bodies,
I’m afraid of meeting these people who are
dumping bodies in the river.
If they see you, they might kill you and dump
you too.
So that makes me afraid of being out at night
An investigative team from the capital Nairobi
has arrived to find out why these bodies are
being dumped in the river and who is responsible.
Until then, the river Yala will continue to
hold the secret to this grim mystery.